CSS also supports background images and
this feature can be used to achieve
a number of responsive effects.
You can use CSS to add a background
pattern to an element or
the page itself.
And you can combine that with
gradients and other CSS effects.
It's possible to get some
incredible effects with pure CSS.
Check out the examples on the website
linked to below the video.
With the background size cover property,
CSS can also be
used to add a background image that
resizes without squashing or stretching.
And again, this can be really handy for
using images when you don't
know the size of the viewport.
The details in a photo can
get lost when it's shrunk, so
this example displays the whole
image if the viewport is
more than 500 pixels wide,
or a smaller crop otherwise.
I've added a CSS transition, so
there's not too much of a jolt
if you resize the window.
You'll see that in the DefTools,
the smaller koala crop is displayed,
downloaded when the window is small.
And then,
if you resize the window larger,
the larger crop is downloaded and
displayed.
CSS background images can be used for
conditional display of images
depending on the viewport size,
using CSS like this.
As you can see from the dev tools, the
background image file is not downloaded
if the viewpoint width
is less than 500 pixels.
Now, you'll find out more
about media queries later.
And a much less hacky and, and
a much more efficient way to
accomplish alternative image loading
when we look at the source set attribute
and the picture element in lesson three.
With background images, you can
also use the CSS Image Set function
to choose a background image
depending on screen resolution.
This example displays a 2x color
image on a high resolution display,
like my phone, and
a 1x monochrome image, otherwise.
For the devices that
don't support Image Set,
the CSS falls back to the 1x version.
If you check the dev tools,
you'll see that only the appropriate
image is downloaded.
You'll learn a lot more about responding
to screen resolution in lesson three.